[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va surveiller bien sûr ce qui va se
passer du côté de la corée du nord parce
qu'après l'escaladent l'apaisement qui
eût cru ya quelques semaines à peine qui
aurait sept mètres tendu par kim jong-un
vers la corée du sud qu'on verrait les
deux pays les deux frères ennemis assis
face à face à la même table en train de
dialoguer trêve apaisement mais pour
appliquer sur le fond rien n'est réglé
parce que la corée du nord si elle son
arsenal balistique et nucléaire et du
côté de la corée du sud et des
occidentaux
eh bien on tient aussi pour l'instant à
ces sanctions qui ont été prises à
l'encontre de pyongyang
mais pour l'instant un apaisement et
bien sûr dans les prochaines semaines
nous serons aux jeux olympiques d'hiver
en corée du sud ou avoir une délégation
nord coréenne parade et participer à ces
jeux donc c'est une quinzaine olympique
qui promet d'être riche en symboles et
en émotions en chine 2018 marque le
début de l'ère 2 2 chez jean ping le
président chinois qui a vu son pouvoir
consolider il ya quelques semaines
quelques mois
donc qu'est-ce que ça laisse présager
pour les libertés individuelles et
collectives
quand on pense que le président chinois
a bien averti qu'il fallait tout faire
pour contrer ce qui pourrait venir
menacé l'autorité du parti communiste et
la masse et des messages clairs entre
autres aux gens de taiwan qui auraient
des velléités indépendantistes
et quand on sait que la liberté
d'expression la liberté de parole sont
très contrôlés que l'internet là bas et
même censuré souvent et au moment où il
ya un resserrement intérieur et bien sûr
jean ping se fait le chantre de la
mondialisation en disant que son pays
serait plus ouvert encore par exemple
aux entreprises étrangères
donc on voit que chez jean ping veut
étendre l'influencé géostratégiques
politiques de son pays veut faire en
sorte que la chine renoue avec sa
splendeur d'antan
[Musique]
cette année qu'adviendra-t-il des
centaines de milliers d'heureux unia qui
ont fui la répression la violence au
myanmar pour se retrouver dans dix quand
du côté du bangladesh
on parle le processus de rapatriement
mais les contours en reste flou et
retourner vers quoi parce qu'on fait
état de villages qui ont brûlé est
retourné dans quelles conditions parce
que les réunions sont privées de droits
et ils risquent ils craignent pour leur
sécurité une fois de retour aux
miaulements ils sont considérés comme
des étrangers
en attendant de savoir ce que l'avenir
leur réserve et bien l'héroïne ya vivent
dans des conditions d'insalubrité
il ya beaucoup d'enfants on parle de
dizaines de milliers de naissance
attendue
il ya des risques sécuritaires
sanitaires et on peut rappeler que la
forte majorité de ces réfugiés sont des
femmes et des enfants